but first tonight Democrats are holding
yet another primary debate at this hour
this one in Las Vegas for the first time
former Mayor Michael Bloomberg will be
standing on the stage his campaign felt
it was important to tell NBC News that
he will not be perched on a box this
evening it's not clear if they were
bragging about that or not
in fact Bloomberg shouldn't be on the
stage at all for a full year the
Democratic Party maintained clear rules
about who qualified for their debates
candidates needed to meet a polling
threshold they also needed donations
from a large pool of people and that was
on purpose the point was to ensure that
candidates had actual grassroots support
and weren't say using their vast
personal fortunes to buy name
recognition with slick TV ads during
Judge Judy and rise mechanically in the
polls they didn't want that candidates
like Cory Booker and Julian Castro
complained bitterly about these rules
and asked for them to be changed but the
DNC wouldn't budge it wouldn't be fair
to make exceptions they said and then
Mayor Mike arrived first he sent a
$300,000 bribe to the DNC last November
just two days before entering the race
and then he sprayed cash on every living
Democrat willing to work for him and
there were many by the end of January
the DNC had changed its mind in all this
and then it changed the rules the party
get rid of the donor requirement
suddenly magically the richest man ever
to run for president qualified for the
debate hmm in other words Bloomberg
bought his way in that's his plan to win
the nomination that's his plan to win
the election in case you're wondering
where there's a connection between
wealth and political power Michael
Bloomberg is here to confirm it in fact
he's decided to prove to all of us that
our democracy is fake that a man with a
blank personality and not a single
popular idea can become president anyway
purely on the strength of 30-second TV
spots that he's paid for himself here's
one of the latest of those there's
nobody that I respect more and felt more
respected by Mike believes excellence is
not defined by gender Mike builds a
culture that
advances women is a foster parent of 20
kids there's times where you need
flexibility with your schedule and Mike
was always supportive of that
Mike supports women he promotes women
and he respects women Mike supports
women Mike respects women right if you
have to say that you know it isn't true
obviously just ask the pregnant employee
Bloomberg ordered to get an abortion
when Mike Bloomberg
becomes the feminist candidate you'll
know we've entered a world of pure lying
but that's the world of the Democratic
National Committee
before long Bloomberg will be on stage
with Gloria Steinem or some other relic
of second wave feminism telling you how
he's devoted his entire life to
shattering glass ceilings or to the
cause of trans rights or to putting an
etching of an illegal immigrant caravan
coming up from Oaxaca on the $20 bill
out with Jackson in with the sacred
undocumented or whatever seems to work
at the moment whatever it takes
it's not pretty it may degrade our
system beyond saving but if it stops
Bernie Sanders from winning the
Democratic establishment is all for it